pour sortir le moins possible cet
habitant de des rousses peut compter sur
son entourage pour les congés des bons
voisins des gentils voisins ou des amis
voilà pour faciliter l'approvisionnement
à domicile la mairie vient de mettre en
place un système de livraison ce matin
un bénévole vient chercher un panier de
fruits et légumes
le primeur a reçu la commande par
téléphone avec le confinement
il a revu toute son organisation en
drive ou en livraison
les clients sont nombreux salons de la
sécurité pour éviter d'avoir à sortir de
chez eux pour avoir
enfin la peur de sortir des grandes
surfaces et puis et puis au moins moi ça
m'apporte plus de plus de bénéfices par
rapport aux gens qui ne connaissaient
pas le magasin non plus une quinzaine de
commerçants est organisée avec la mairie
deux fois par semaine les bénévoles font
le tour des magasins et livre les
clients avec le plus de distance
possible
benoît s'est tout de suite porté
volontaire ça diversifie les l'offre
qu'on apporte aux clients peu livres et
des magazines s'il faut on peut livrer
du pain on peut livrer comme
des paniers de fruits et légumes
donc ça ça permet d'offrir un service
supplémentaire
la municipalité veut toucher le plus de
monde possible
on a fait une communication via le site
internet de la mairie et les réseaux
sociaux
mais tout le monde n'a pas internet donc
on a décidé de distribuer les tracts
dans les boîtes aux lettres pour essayer
la forme et le maximum de personnes du
nouveau service de livraison en fait
qu'on a mis en place pour l'instant la
mairie a identifié une soixantaine de
personnes isolées avec ce système elle
espère bien on aider davantage